I was betrayed by my own blood recently
I found out that my middle child has
been eating Supermarket choc chip
muffins these things have over 20
ingredients in there and they're heavily
processed my chocolate chip muffins are
so much better they're nutritious
they've hardly got any ingredients and I
know what I've put in them I'm going to
control his spending and stop giving him
pocket money just have a look at these
they're huge they're chocolatey they
have everything that he could possibly
need I mean no joke here your muffins
look fire anytime you want a FedEx me
some baked goods across the pond I will
definitely pay the duties no problem but
I feel like we don't need to freak out
about this and like take your kids
pocket money away a muffin with 20
ingredients may be slightly less
nutritious than yours which has 13
ingredients but at the end of the day
they're both mainly chocolate delicious
yes but no one should be aiming to get
their antioxidants fiber and protein
from a triple chocolate muffin no matter
what the ingredients are so I agree that
homemade just always hits different and
if you were my mom I assure you I would
not betray you but big nutrition picture
I feel we got bigger fish to fry next